ceux qui arrivent maintenant ils
viennent pour râler eux ils ont fait ils
vont ils ont fait la nouvelle star on ne
les reconnaît pas alors juste valeur ils
veulent ouvrir le pousser un coup de
gueule petit récap de la Nouvelle Star
et des absents de la Nouvelle Star le
temps de leur remercie encore et c'était
vraiment cette anne honneur pour moi
vous venez merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
cette petite ritournelle devenue culte
c'est le générique de l'émission tout
aussi cul de M6 la Nouvelle Star arrêtez
depuis 2017 le mythique talent show fait
cette année ses 20 ans d'existence j'ai
l'impression d'ouvrir une bonne et pour
l'occasion ce mercredi M6 a proposé la
première de ces deux soirées spéciales
au téléspectateur
[Applaudissements]
13 saisons la nouvelle star a révélé de
nombreux talents qui sont aujourd'hui
des artistes incontournables de la scène
musicale française comme Christophe
Willem Amel Bent ou encore Julien Doré
c'est pas ma faute
et sur le plateau cette semaine certains
artistes étaient bizarrement absents
alors que la chaîne avait communiqué
sureau dans la bande-annonce en effet
pas de Cindy Sanders ou de Xavier Matheo
le gagnant de la dernière saison sur
scène est-ce que ça va bouger surfends à
fond sur la nostalgie le programme n'a
pourtant convaincu qu'à peine de
millions de téléspectateurs qui ont
quand même pu se régaler en réentendant
les fameuses casseroles qui ont
grandement contribué au succès du show
et
[Applaudissements]
au fond de moi
un autre prime événement est prévu
mercredi prochain rassemblera-t-il plus
de personnes devant la télé et surtout
aurons-nous la chance d'y apercevoir les
artistes refoulés du premier prime
et sur la Xavier matheuse Cindy Sanders
et Bruno Monroe merci beaucoup
l'année dernière était venue ça c'était
pas très bien passé avec Hugo manos et
il en veut à personne non voilà c'est ça
un artiste je suis très fâché
pourquoi on m'a dit dans les loges
j'espère que c'est faux parce que je ne
peux pas y croire c'est pas ma Cindy on
m'a dit dans les loges Cindy Sander
refuse de me refaire la vraie version
qui bouge et tout et tout juste le
refrain de papillon de lumière j'ai dit
c'est pas Maxime dit ça vous avez vous
avez mal
parlés quand même depuis donc passons
et qui nous font chier grave vieille
chanson
plus acoustique c'est beaucoup ah non
mais nous on veut l'entendre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors effectivement c'est un peu les
refoulés de nouvelles stars ce que l'on
n'a pas très bien compris donc la
semaine dernière ça part très bien
marché d'ailleurs ils ont repassé les
Hamel ben les Julien Doré tout ça tout
ça tout ça mais effectivement bah il y a
eu beaucoup beaucoup d'absents alors
Cindy vous par exemple vous aperçu dans
un petit reportage consacré à Julien
Doré on va regarder l'extrait mais c'est
tout après vous avez disparu après la
Nouvelle Star donc 2008 où j'ai
participé je reçois un appel donc de son
producteur à l'époque qui me dit voilà
Julien Doré aimerait chanter avec toi
sur scène donc là je me dis je m'y
attend pas du tout il y a eu une
personne dans le public qui a été
pas très gentil on va dire et lui a tout
de suite dit ferme
ta gueule il leur a dit à tous c'est mon
invité et je veux que voilà faites-lui
le plus grand des applaudissements soyez
vraiment chaleureux avec elle elle a du
talent elle le mérite
et ça a été un duo mais fabuleux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Nouvelle Star j'ai commencé j'évite
zappé parce que ça m'a voilà ça m'a un
petit peu énervé et est-ce que vous
attendez à quoi une sorte de donner un
couple pas un peu de cette émission
toute sa gueule en le regrette non mais
je me suis dit après tout ce que André
Manoukian a dit dernièrement en plateau
il a avoué lui-même que j'ai été
manipulé par la prod voilà ensuite de
dire que je suis un accident industriel
alors il faut savoir que si ça c'est un
accident industriel à avoir rempli une
salle de 3000 personnes chaque soir
pendant 3 ans avec 800 000 spectateurs
alors je suis un accident industriel
mais magnifique voilà pourquoi vous leur
dites pas merci tout simplement
que je pense qu'à cette occasion là ça
aurait été un moment pour montrer aux
gens que voilà on passe à autre chose et
même pour moi vous croyez pas que après
15 ans j'ai beaucoup de souffert de
cette situation par rapport aux
producteurs heureusement que Thierry
Mugler m'a tendu la main parce que en
France il y a cette image de Cindy
Sanders la nouvelle star on s'arrête là
et vous dit tout est manipulé dans
l'émission bien sûr ça veut dire quoi
tout est manipulé de A à Z puisque je
j'arrive au casting on me fait doubler
une file d'attente de 8 heures parce que
j'ai le physique qu'ils ont envie ils
ont des critères ensuite on me ramène on
me dit voilà non non il faut pas chanter
ça et ça il faut faire un medley il faut
faire des caisses il faut faire beaucoup
de mouvements ce que je fais et en fin
de compte on me dit de
on fait venir des caméras là le
lendemain chez moi en organise un
concert qui n'a pas lieu du tout on ne
fait croire que je suis vraiment la
gagnante de de
jusqu'au bout et encore avant de rentrer
en plateau me dit Cindy on sait ce que
la production cherche faisant des
caisses c'est toi la Nouvelle Star cette
année mais c'est pas trop dur quand vous
dites vous dites j'évite zappé ils ont
diffusé des casseroles c'est pas normal
de se de la gueule des gens qui
viennent pour tout avec toute la bonne
volonté du monde ça s'appelle du
harcèlement ce que j'ai subi un peu fort
non non
quand tu vis depuis 15 ans du
harcèlement à travers les réseaux
sociaux où les gens se cachent derrière
leur écran à écrire des méchancetés ou
alors les producteurs la preuve Monsieur
Thierry Mugler et aller voir des grands
producteurs français avant d'aller à
Berlin il a présenté ma maquette il a
dit voilà je voudrais vous faire écouter
quelque chose de Cindy Sanders
on n'en veut pas c'est ringard c'est has
been c'est une nouvelle star ok il prend
sa petite valise il repart il m'appelle
il me raconte ça et il retourne quelques
semaines après et il dit voilà j'ai une
jeune Québécoise écoutez juste ça ils
écoutent et qu'est-ce qu'ils disent
ouais mais elle a une voix magnifique
c'est qui on en veut et là Manfred leur
dit ben vous savez c'est la fille
ringarde de la Nouvelle Star quand vous
dites quand même la nouvelle star a
bloqué ma carrière pardon aussi mais ça
aurait été quoi votre carrière aussi sur
nos nouvelles stars il faut essayer de
parfois être un peu honnête que dans mon
malheur j'ai eu ma chance de rencontrer
Thierry Mugler et après au niveau de la
France et encore aujourd'hui je le crie
haut et fort parce que la France on va
être réaliste les critères sont bien
fermés si tu fais pas partie de la
famille tu ne rentres pas voilà et Cindy
Sanders et ben sa jeune même si elle a
une belle voix même si elle a du
potentiel Cindy Sander de la Nouvelle
Star ça gêne c'est l'étiquette que la
nouvelle star a bien voulu me mettre
vous êtes là même si vous n'avez pas
voulu chanter et ça je suis pas content
je trouve que c'est pas cool Bruno
bonjour Vous final non ah oui moi j'ai
fait tous les primes sauf deux j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance alors moi j'ai un
parcours complètement différent du tien
moi j'étais le petit garçon qui
regardait la nouvelle star avec ses yeux
d'enfants et qui a vécu un vrai conte de
fées moi M6 ils ont toujours été
adorable avec moi incroyable à défaut je
suis le plus gros célibataire de France
encore
au moins je sais faire un truc c'est
déjà bien en toute humilité mais ouais
enfin moi j'ai eu un petit parcours à la
Cendrillon j'étais le petit prince à la
française c'est vrai même de
physiquement oui bah oui
comme il chantait il est fascinant quand
il chante hein
[Musique]
dans sa fleur tu fais tourner de ton nom
tous les mots là de mon cœur
j'ai une question
j'ai une question pardon à l'époque moi
je regardais
vous avez une voix incroyable vous êtes
beaux garçons il faut le dire merci au
départ il y a tous les critères
qu'est-ce qui fait j'ai pas la réponse
qu'une carrière ça va ça prend ça va pas
manger la réponse à ça moi je suis
quelqu'un de très spirituel je mange pas
de viande enfin tout ça c'est très ça
va ça va avec le truc alors je
t'explique je pense que dans la vie il y
a peu de temps j'ai croisé Slimane je le
connais très bien on avait fait les plus
belles voix de la télé-réalité sur NRJ12
et on avait pas on avait partagé la même
chambre pendant cette semaine et Slimane
m'a dit il y a peu de temps il m'a dit
j'ai toujours été fan de toi à la
Nouvelle Star je dis ah bon et tout tu
me l'as jamais dit pourtant ce qu'on est
depuis un bout de temps il me dit oui
mais tu sais ce qui fait que moi j'ai
fait carrière et pas toi je dis ben non
il m'a dit le facteur chance et le
facteur rencontre il m'a dit c'est ce
qui t'a manqué dans ta vie j'ai dit mais
tu sais j'ai 38 ans il y a des gens qui
commencent leur carrière à 50 ans moi
j'ai la chance d'être dans le dans le
métier depuis 20 on peut pas se dire
aussi la vérité
c'était une phrase de monomy fogier je
le répète parce que j'aurais dû aussi me
l'appliquer une carrière c'est savoir
dire non et au début quand on débute on
dit oui à tout parce qu'on a peur et on
fait des parfois des mauvais choix et
après c'est des étiquettes je pense que
les anges c'est pas les meilleures
choses que vous ayez faites et ben
écoute moi honnêtement je suis très fier
des anges tu sais moi je me rappelle de
toi enfin on a partagé beaucoup de Mad
mag à l'époque sur la route oui je sais
mais quand même je sais pas si tu te
souviens Mathieu mais je vais te taper
quelque chose parce que tu connais
l'histoire de ouais alors
tu te rappelles que quand même grâce aux
anges une fois dans notre vie toi et moi
on pourra dire qu'on a rempli l'avenue
des Champs-Élysées ah c'est bon avec une
dédicace des anges ok c'est vrai la rue
des Champs exactement
et alors Bruno Monroe donc formidable
mais après c'est comme Mireille ma belle
vous chantez aussi à côté
[Applaudissements]
tu peux comprendre il y a tellement
d'émissions il y a tellement eu de trucs
et tout ça s'est arrêté pendant des
années et exactement alors c'est de qui
de ma part c'est pas grave c'est la
semaine prochaine Ludivine sera ravi
d'être là on va on va regarder quand
vous chantez merci
et toi tu n'es pas là
et si je rêve tant pis quand tu t'en vas
je dors plus la nuit
mais tu n'es pas là
et tu sais j'ai envie
d'aller là-bas la fenêtre d'en face et
visiter ton paradis
et comme on l'a pas fait honneur Jean
mais vraiment j'adore je suis pas ça à
côté la victoire
Nouvelle Star 2017 la Nouvelle Star
et Xavier
[Applaudissements]
et
pourquoi pourquoi vous a pas invité sur
les plans franchement franchement je
vais dire que ça a été quand même une
surprise parce que quand j'ai vu que ça
ça revenait un petit peu je me suis dit
bah tu es quand même à gagner voilà j'ai
gagné après ces 5 ans ou c'est que moi
quand même j'ai parlé de la Nouvelle
Star je l'ai porté dans tous les petits
plateaux que j'ai réussi à faire les
promotions j'étais quand même aussi
dernièrement déferlantes que vous
connaissez j'ai porté ça et de voir que
ça reprend et qui m'invite pas à
souffler la bougie j'étais un peu
touchée vraiment dégueulasse c'est
qu'ils ont mis un doré Christophe
Willems
qui avait une belle voix mais qui compte
pas forcément et ça peut venir encore
mais pour pas forcément décoller on les
a mis de côté genre on montre que ceux
non c'est pas normal ici c'est normal tu
veux qu'on prenne The Voice en 15 ans
ils en ont sorti deux
l'audience donc ils prennent
les pointures donc ils prennent Julien
Doré ils prennent la tortues
est-ce que vous vivez la musique
aujourd'hui je suis intermittent du
spectacle quand même parce que avant ça
bon moi j'ai quand même 10 ans de
percussions je suis percussionniste
musicien voilà donc
j'ai réussi à reprendre j'étais
mécanicien aussi pendant 10 ans moi j'ai
pas envie vraiment de cracher dessus
parce que quelque part pour moi c'était
quelque chose d'exceptionnel j'ai une
vie active
mais pour en revenir à ma vie voilà pour
moi ça a été comme vraiment quelque
chose d'extraordinaire parce que bon
comme je vous l'ai dit j'ai 10 ans de
mécanique j'ai une fille aussi qui
s'appelle Zoé j'ai tout voulu faire pour
elle mais Xavier Xavier Xavier
pardon Bruno quand on fait ça quand on
connaît ça quand on entend les gens qui
chantent comme ça on se dit c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est comme Myriam
bébé
on fait notre métier comment tu gagnes
par mois
en France je paye pas mes impôts à Dubaï
alors je vais pas le dire
voilà ça a été quand même un moment
extraordinaire parce que comme aussi la
di Jean-Michel il veut faire dans les
émissions précédentes que j'ai pu
regarder dans les loges en replay j'ai
vu que ça parlait beaucoup d'actifs
d'addictologie tout ça donc moi aussi
j'ai été touché par ça d'ailleurs je
remercie SOS France qui m'a beaucoup
aidé à m'en sortir ils sont toujours
derrière moi pour essayer de voir si je
veux pas parler au nom de ça je l'ai pas
fait jusqu'à aujourd'hui mais comme j'ai
vu que tout le monde aujourd'hui j'ai eu
envie aussi de de parler de ça donc pour
moi l'addition ça voilà la nouvelle star
en fait ça a redonné de la lumière à ma
vie ma mère qui me pensait perdue que
genre j'embrasse ici vous avez une super
histoire pour pouvoir
la chanson ces émissions c'est des c'est
de l'émotions aujourd'hui je suis venu
pour clôturer le sujet parce que on est
beaucoup concerné par rapport à la
nouvelle star à avoir souffert il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont fait ce casting
et qui malheureusement ben on finit très
très mal heureusement que moi j'étais
très bien entourée donc c'est pour ça
que je suis là aujourd'hui pour faire
comprendre aux gens que la télé reste la
télé arrêtez d'écouter et de croire tout
ce qu'on vous dit arrêtez de vous
arrêter à ça parce qu'il y a des gens
derrière comme nous des humains qui
souffrant moi j'ai souffert pendant
pendant presque 15 ans heureusement que
mon mari était là et mon fils parce que
pour moi c'était très dur d'entendre et
de voir des gens me dire tu es qu'une
grosse merde va va te va te faire tuer
des injures mais pas possible alors que
j'ai fait le conservatoire
plus important ce qu'on y met si avant
si avant ça avant de revenir déjà avant
parce que
vous avez une vie un peu ancrée dans les
choses basiques et naturel je pense que
vous l'aurez peut-être moins bien pris
moins mal pris en tout cas si vous avez
plein de choses c'est vrai que c'est
impressionnant c'est pas une question de
rêve c'était vraiment une question que
je chante depuis toute petite alors je
ne suis pas une diva comme certains
le dis tu te vois à moi j'ai mon
parcours à moi et je trouve que c'est
dégueulasse qu'une émission telle que la
leur puisse écraser des jeunes artistes
qui croient en eux alors il y a ceux qui
ont plus ou moins de talent mais il faut
qu'on arrête c'était les de merde
on les a fait découvrir heureusement je
suis là aujourd'hui grâce à ça OK
la semaine prochaine moi ce que je veux
dire c'est que Bruno chante toujours il
a envie il est heureux votre je vous
connaissez pas vous connaissez pas je
vous découvre aujourd'hui
et vous aviez dit que j'étais à l'abri
des séances d'autographes mais
aujourd'hui
je suis pas l'abri des trucs comme ça
c'était 2022 le matin on est en 2023
intelligence